hi caitlin how are you i am doing well
how are you doing i'm doing well thank
you for talking to me about this i
thought you were just terrific in this
and this is
clearly not easy material this story is
heartbreaking it's tragic it made me
want to scream
what was it about this project that made
you want to tell this story why was it
important to you
yeah i
it is some it is something that makes
you so in
just
en enraged with anger and
it make me want to scream when i first
read it um
because the injustice of it was just
super surprising to me because i i
didn't know a lot about the
opioid crisis i i knew
just really that i knew
that it existed i didn't know about the
purdue pharma and sackler family
side of it and how
it all began uh
so i i just
immediately thought it was for that
reason a story that deserved to be told
because it it caused
so much
pain and suffering between just
the people being
the victims of the drug but also the
people being affected by that and the
the
families with loved ones that they lost
and there's just continent continues now
even today so i think that
the fact that we were able to shed light
on that and and and in an honest way i
think it was just
immediately so
so important for me
this is the second mini series you've
done in recent years uh he also did
terrific work and unbelievable
what do you enjoy about the opportunity
to really get to explore a character
more deeply in that way especially when
it comes to someone like this character
what aspects of her did you enjoy
exploring that you likely wouldn't have
gotten to explore if this were a film
i
yeah that's so true that that's
something i really think about a lot
when i'm
when i'm
diving in to do uh
a film you know with a film you don't
have
you don't have the amount of time to
really
you know take the time and to go deeper
and explore even more um
so
with the
with a show like this and the fact that
i had you know many episodes to work
with we were able to really carve out
and take the time and really explore the
nuances of betsy and really
take the time to
go on that journey with her and to
really follow the the tragedy and the
heartbreak and um
to see where she started from too and
she started from such a
[Music]
you know
i mean
happy you used lightly because there are
a lot of things in her life that she was
still internalizing and figuring out but
she was figuring it out and she was
working it out and she was
coming from a place of really loving her
job and and then
um
wanting to move away with her
her girlfriend and then
really just after that her life just
completely takes a turn because of the
drug and um i think because of
the
limited series format we were able to
really really get a really good glimpse
at um her storyline and
what she deals with and what she goes
through
her story is a very familiar story in
this particular epidemic in crisis
she's a young woman who's just trying to
get by until she has an accident gets
hurt ends up in pain and takes a
prescription given to her by a doctor
which sort of spirals everything
so what do you hope viewers see in her
story do you hope that watching
what she goes through might help people
have empathy for others like her instead
of just a quick rush to judgment
i think
that's the biggest reason why i wanted
to be a part of it because i really felt
like even it changed my
it changed the way i view
um
the crisis it gave me more information
um but it also allowed me even me to
have more empathy so i think that
um
i think that
telling this story
um in such an honest way we are
my hope is that the audience will really
look at betsy's story in particular and
have more empathy towards people
dealing with
addiction or family members that have
lost a loved one or
um
i i really do believe that that it is a
really really powerful story and i think
it will do that and more for people how
did you find the experience of working
with michael keaton what was he like as
a scene partner what do you learn from
working with someone who is really sort
of an acting legend like him
he's just it's working with him is still
honestly like settling in in my brain
because it's just so
it's so mind-blowing to me that i get to
have that opportunity to work with him
um
he really is it's just a bucket list
actor for me and
um
working with him was such a joy he is
i i
it's like just he doesn't even have to
say anything to me to for it to be a
master class and getting to watch him um
was the master class and
uh
everything he says is he says with such
honesty and you believe every single
word that comes out of his mouth and
he's just he's so good
he's so good
do you personally have a favorite role
of his that you've seen just from his
past career i was talking about this
earlier i think it i mean obviously it's
batman
he's amazing batman
but my personal favorite is movie he did
called jack frost because
that movie shaped
me and my
me my sister we watched it just non-stop
growing up so um it's a role that i
really really enjoy
i love that movie so much
i i have a permanent beetlejuice shaped
you know hole in my place in my heart
for yes
it's right up there as well
well you were so truly terrific doing
dramatic work but do you ever wish you
could do more comedy i mean is it
something you'd like to do more of i
know you've done some but certainly not
as much as the dramatic work that you do
well it's funny because i'm now like the
rest of this year is dedicated to comedy
so i just did a comedy i'm doing another
comedy
um at the end of the year and um
so i'm i'm mixing it up i'm i and with
book smart in there too i i
i
i think it's it gets maybe evened out
now
i first became aware of your work when
you did justified which
was the first time you played a
character almost from the start to the
finish of that series is that a
character that always will hold a
special place in your heart is that
someone that you really enjoy getting to
follow the journey of
i
so enjoyed playing that character i live
i lived with it for such a long time
and it
i mean
it has a special place in my heart yes
because of the character but also just
the people that i worked with they're
just so lovely and and just
really just
awesome they feel like my family i still
keep in touch with a lot of them and
they're just so
i just had a really really special time
on that show and um
i i
i it's really just a an unforgettable
experience that one it's still
one of the best so
i i love justified so much it's very
very very special to me
how hard is it to become invested in a
story like this that
you know there's no resolution to the
lives and the families that were
affected by this or permanently altered
when you tell a real life story like
that that doesn't have a happy ending is
it hard to
let go of that weight
um
it definitely is i think i i think i
carry the weight
with me for even longer than i even
realized
um
[Music]
you know for this role i really just and
for a lot of i mean for even even
unbelievable that
both of these stories
felt so much bigger than me and they and
they are
uh
and so i for for dope sick i was really
just i i caught myself just like
completely forgetting about myself and
the way i felt in these like more
intense
moments or when i had a harder day on
set i just really just
took myself away from it because i knew
that i had a
i had a
responsibility and a duty to serve this
this story and to serve the text
and
make it make sure that i was doing it
right and so i felt like if i if i were
thinking about myself that just would
just be completely like
unhelpful and also it's just like not
about
not about me it's about
making sure that i'm
telling the story of betsy mallum which
in turn represents like a whole group of
people and i um
i really i really just uh
it was it was hard you know
but it
it was also just nothing
nothing in comparison to to what victims
actually do go through so um
i was able to i was able to you know
it's it's a hard thing to shake off for
sure so i but eventually
i think i'm
able to just then be be proud of what
everybody made and now that it's coming
out i mean i didn't finish it much like
i didn't finish it
it wasn't that long ago that i was
wrapped on this and now it's coming out
so it's a it was a quick turnaround and
i'm very grateful that people are going
to finally see it
well i appreciate you talking to me
about it i definitely understand why you
would want to go to columbia after this
so
thank you for talking to me about it
so much
you